critical points is the term that you'll
find in textbooks and sometimes
occasionally in exam all they mean by
critical is important and they are
important in different ways okay so what
I'm going to do is start to talk about
I'm just going to introduce two kinds of
critical points we'll have more to
introduce later but these are the ones
that have to do with the first
derivative okay so the first time of
critical points what we call a
stationary point now I'm just the key
around anything a ball something around
and I confer it's round enough okay now
here's our here's my object okay now I
just want you to watch it very carefully
I'm throwing it up and down okay now if
we were to UM graph the motion of this
Apple okay over time all that's doing is
going up and down right I just go in
okay it's just going up and down it's
not going side to side or and if you
like that okay now therefore if i graph
it okay let's think about this I would
like you graph this was very simple
let's graph I guess I'm talking about
how high it is right that's the only
thing that's changing right so we'll
call my hand right like zero okay that's
where it starts okay and this axis here
we could call it Y I suppose but it
would be better to call it your H for
height okay now what would be this axis
over here
remember it's not moving sideways it's
just going up and down okay
this axis here would be time I guess I'm
thinking about it as time progresses
okay
so now if you watch it right hurt me to
higher sorry I promise this is really
over too high just to try it illustrate
something okay I want you to pay
attention to how fast the Apple is
moving okay not just that it's going up
and down but how quickly is it going up
and down okay now this is probably gonna
go out the video but anyway let's just
try I'm not thinking about its force I'm
thinking about how fast it's moving
okay ready so let's see huh of course I
get to the roof okay okay now hopefully
does it not times I don't want one more
for good measure
you might have noticed okay that when is
it going fastest when is going faster
just as it leaves my hand right because
I I push it up right and the second I
let go of her it starts to slow down you
notice where does it go slowest at the
very top in fact it's not just going
slower it stops okay in other words it
is um it's stationary right that's where
this word comes from okay
and then it comes back down and again it
reaches the same speed as it's coming
back to my hair okay
so therefore if i graph this thing what
does it look like well it starts off
really fast but then it starts to slow
down and eventually it stops and then it
comes back down that fashion okay
now please get it can I get across to
you right this here does not correspond
to me like throwing the Apple from me to
someone else there's no horizontal
movement here from here here is time as
time progresses
okay so for instance you know I don't
know how long it took to get to the top
maybe say one and a half seconds okay
after one half seconds it's at the top
okay that's the high of Siegert and
after three seconds right I catch it
again okay so there's no horizontal
movement down
the key of course is together you can he
Co doesn't be funny if after all the
times I was like catching so this point
that we're talking about right the point
at which it stops the printer which is
going slowest we call this a stationary
boil because if you imagine the graph
like an apple like any object that's
moving okay it's moving very very
quickly and then at this point it stops
it's stationary
and then it starts moving again in a
different direction okay so there's a
couple of things we can notice about
this right this point here right if we
were to draw a tangent to the graph at
that point what kind of tangent would it
be what kind of line
right so okay
at stationary points the tangent is
horizontal now you also know that the
horizontal lines they have a gradient
off zero because there's no rides
there's lots of run but no rise okay
so therefore the derivative dy on DX is
equal to zero so another way to think
about this is the other way around we
have talked about this in more detail a
second but if you want you to find a
stationary point okay you would say
stationary points exist and by putting
this in quite Marx is it's an important
phrase you need to get stationary points
exist when dy/dx is equal to zero if we
had some different kind of graph okay
and I was going to solve this equation I
would find all the places sorry take
that back all the places that I find
would be stationary okay I'm gonna talk
about some calories every in a second
yeah okay I'm gonna say yes and I'm
gonna justify that in a second okay so
that's what that's part why I put in
quite not so stationary points the
important things to get it's called a
stationary point because the thing
you're that's moving the graph is still
not stop the tangent that were in
horizontal and this is what the
derivative is equal to at that point